so life expectancy in the united states  is back down to mid 90s levels we've  essentially lost more than 20 years of  life expectancy gains and it's mostly  covered although it's also some other  things including cardiac issues  and part of this is related not to covid  directly but to the fact that kovid  pushed some people to delay screenings  and certain things were diagnosed later  in any case it's a horrible thing it has  affected  alaska  natives and american indians as they are  now known more than some other groups  and  it could potentially take  a really long time to even recover those  numbers absolutely and completely  horrifying